willkommen im internet sehen und was war
gründe rum wie aufzählungen nicht
widerstehen können und warum diese frau
ihre zuschauer verarscht jetzt bei miley
[Musik]
listiges artikel oder beiträge in
listenform überschwemmen das internet
weiß wie unglaublich gut funktioniert
warum
daher war uns manche so hart klick beten
dass wir gar nicht anders kann aber es
gibt noch mehr hier ziehen
wissenschaftliche gründe nummer eins
zahlen fallen auf wenn dem internet
unterwegs sind und durch so ein vieh
trollen werden wir überflutet mit
bildern und artikeln bevor wir uns
überhaupt bewusst dafür entscheiden ob
wir auf einen artikel draufklicken wurde
auf ein video muss es uns erst mal
auffallen
alles was anders ist als der rest als
das irgendwie aus der reihe tanzt fällt
uns ins auge das wurde auch schon mit
eye tracking experimenten gemessen
natürlich ist es im heutigen internet
fast schon unmöglich geworden überhaupt
noch irgendwie aufzufallen aber trotzdem
ist es ein visueller bruch wenn eine
zahl in einem titel voller buchstaben
steht was im allerersten moment
aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht nummer
zwei wir lieben es dinge zu gruppieren
wir verarbeiten informationen indem wir
sie in kleinere stücke zerteilen genau
wie es eine liste tut das könnte man
natürlich sagen so ein basket artikel
sind keine informationen da gibt es doch
nichts zu verarbeiten naja also auch
diese blaue wand ist eine information
die hier natürlich erstmal verarbeiten
muss das können wir sogar kurz testen
wie viele punkte seht ihr hier
[Musik]
und wie viele sind hier
wie seid ihr beim zählen vorgegangen
habe jetzt die punkte einzeln abgezielt
nein wahrscheinlich habt ihr sie eher in
gruppen eingeteilt
obwohl es natürlich nicht schwierig ist
ein paar punkte zu zählen benutzen wir
das hilfsmittel gruppieren sobald es
mehr als sechs punkte sind eine
gedankliche zerlegung in kleinere
gruppen oder kleinere segmente hilft uns
einfach dabei den überblick zu behalten
eine liste oder aufzählung verspricht
uns segmentierte info die uns
häppchenweise präsentiert wird genau wie
unser gehirn es gerne hat aber manche
zahlen sind dabei besser als andere wie
zeit sie ist besonders unwiderstehlich
ihr mögen glatte zahlen als auch weil
wir beim arbeiten von zahlen oft in
szene oder hunderter gruppen denken sie
ähnlich wie bei unserem metrischen ein
heizsystem dass wir in zehnergruppen
denken sieht man auch an sämtlichen
rankingliste top 10 20 50 100 wollen
keine top 9 oder top elf listen obwohl
es prinzipiell genauso interessant wäre
nein wir möchten runde zahlen das deckt
sich auch mit der statistik aus dem
königshaus der listige spa suite die
zahl nummer 10 ist die häufigste listige
länge weil sie wohl am besten
funktioniert und deswegen habe ich euch
heute auch dreist angelogen und gesagt
dass ich zehn gründe habe obwohl ich
eigentlich nur drei gründe habe
verarscht wiesauer seid ihr es stimmt
die roma vielleicht ist euch auch schon
mal aufgefallen dass ein listiges ein
und derselbe punkt mehrfach erwähnt wird
nur anders formuliert oder anders
verpackt das hätte ich natürlich auch
machen können in diesem video um so auf
zehn gründe zu kommen unabhängig von den
runden zahlen erwarten wir von listiges
mit höheren zahlen dass die einzelnen
punkte nicht besonders anspruchsvoll
sein werden wir nicht zehn oder zwanzig
gründe oder fotos oder arten habe dann
erwarte ich kurze leicht verdauliche
infos die ich bei so schnell wegstecken
kann
wenn ich allerdings nur drei gründe habe
dann könnte eventuell jeder grund für
sich
etwas länger und anspruchsvoller sein
zum beispiel sieht noch mal passiert
dass es unterhalb einer zahl von fünf
kaum listiges gibt man einen artikel mit
drei punkten wird halt nicht aus nur
drei sätzen wurde nun drei fotos
bestehen aber wollen wir denn nicht mehr
die tiefe
nummer drei wir mögen quatsch als
einfach ist klar sind viele listiges
dumm aber sie sind auch einfach und das
mögen wir cognitive fluren oder manchmal
auch nur flohen sie beschreibt das
subjektive empfinden darüber wie schwer
oder einfach es uns fällt informationen
zu verarbeiten die einfach etwas zu
verarbeiten ist desto mehr fluent ist es
und es muss jetzt noch nicht mehr so
etwas sein wie quantenphysik wird es das
kleine einmaleins sondern so was wie ein
übersichtliches bild welches ein
unübersichtliches bild und es ist super
interessant wie fluren sie uns
beeinflusst in einer studie zeigte man
verschiedenen leuten immer denselben
satz der aber verschieden gut visuell
lesbar wenn der satz leichter zu lesen
war wurde er auch eher als war empfunden
in einer anderen studie wurden firmen
beobachtet die zum ersten mal an die
börse gingen firmen deren namen einfach
im sinne von fluent waren waren im
schnitt deutlich erfolgreicher als
firmen mit non fluent namen richtiges
sind extrem fluent aus all den gründen
die wir gerade unter punkt 2 besprochen
haben aber auch weil sie in der regel
aus wenig text und vielen fotos oder
gips bestehen und das finden wir super
eine höhere fluence ii führt außerdem zu
einer höheren mietanteil die leute
schauen dieses video er zu ende oder
scrollen den artikel er bis zum ende
lesen also scrollen ja man muss er in
der regel riechen lesen und hier kommt
noch ein wichtiger punkt obendrauf nehme
ich meine musical wissen wir genau wie
viele punkte wir zu erwarten haben
vielleicht kennt ihr das ja auch ihr
habt jetzt zufällig auf 15 gründe war es
auch immer geklickt seit aber nicht so
überzeugt von den ersten fünf gründen in
einem normalen beitrag wird man dieser
stelle wahrscheinlich wegklicken bei
musical hat man aber eine
bestimmte anzahl eine überschaubare
anzahl an punkten vor sich von dem man
schon weiß dass sie nicht wie
anstrengungen von einem verlagen was ein
ehe dazu verführt weiter zuschauen
weiter zu lesen und wer weiß vielleicht
ist ja der letzte punkt gut was denkt
ihr warum sind buzzfeed und co so
erfolgreich mit ihren listen hättet ihr
auch auf dieses video geklickt wenn ich
erst genannt hätte warum wir listen
mögen und findet ihr zehn gründe auch
klicken schwerter oder ansprechende als
drei schreibe es in die kommentare und
in der end card gibt es die zehn besten
listige ist nummer 112 krasse fotos bei
denen dir die luft wegbleibt nummer 28
arten seien müll zu entsorgen nummer 33
zehn lustigsten frisuren von
fußballspielern nummer 14 dinge mit
denen ihr sofort aufhören müsste 513
mysteriöse dinge die selbst
wissenschaftler nicht erklären können
nummer 6 10 fakten die du nicht wissen
möchtest nummer 7 16 fotos bei dem du
schreien musst wenn du bücher liebst wer
ist die zielgruppe bücherwürmer die auch
buzzfeed listen lesen um 85 dinge die
frauen lieben aber zu ängstlich sind zu
fragen gehaltserhöhungen immer neuen 15
menschen die extrem viel glück hatten
beim essen und nummer 10 5 arten von
typen
wir sehen uns nächsten donnerstag freude
in der sonne bleibt sicher